et donc ça va pas vous surprendre mais
on était réuni pour une journée de débat
de réflexion et ça veut dire qu'on n'est
pas systématiquement forcément d'accord
avec tout ce qui est tout ce qui est dit
on est d'accord sur l'essentiel sur 80
90 % et jean-denis julia leigh ne m'en
voudra pas j'ai une petite nuance avec
lui sur son analyse qui fait des traités
européens
bon d'abord premier réflexion je pense
que ça a été dit souligné mais il faut
condamner tous conscience et qu'on le
répète c'est que le phénomène migratoire
est un phénomène profond long durable
pour d'abord pour des raisons
démographiques ce chiffre est toujours
intéressant parce qu'il est
impressionnant
l'afrique compte aujourd'hui 1 milliard
200 millions d'habitants dans 35 ans
elle en comptera 2 milliards quatre cent
mille et s'il le continent africain
voulait maintenir sa population pour
travailler sur place ça signifie qu'il
devrait créer chaque année en plus 29
millions d'emplois sur place la deuxième
raison c'est les changements climatiques
on estime qu'il y aurait dans l'est
aussi trois prochaines décennies
200 à 220 millions de migrants qui se
déplaceraient et puis il ya ce à quoi
mme invite françois noël il y a
effectivement ces pressions migratoires
liés au conflit aux tensions et aux
guerres qu'est ce que ça signifie
derrière les mots rappelle que la syrie
depuis 2011 il ya eu 250 mille tués que
la moitié de la population 11 millions a
été obligé de quitter de fuir son foyer
et qui a quatre millions de syriens qui
sont prêts à bouger qu'ils ont déjà
quitté la syrie qui sont dans certains
pays limitrophes et qui sont prêts en
réalité à migrer ailleurs et notamment
vers le continent européen est en
réalité ça aboutit à quoi ça parle à
voix méditerranéenne 430 mille migrants
depuis le 1er janvier
430 me l'ont dit ça fait beaucoup mais
c'est qu'elle à quoi ça correspond comme
tendance ça correspond très exactement
au doublement 100 % de plus sur la même
période de l'année dernière le
doublement
et puis il ya les
qui sont aussi terrible c'est 2748 tuées
ou disparues enfin qu auraient péri en
mer depuis cette période
et tout ceci ça démontre quoi ça
démontre qu'il ya une voie d'accès de
par la méditerranée qui est totalement
saturée et puisque l'on vient de voir
cette seule facile depuis ces quelques
jours c'est l'accès par la voie des
balkans et ça a été ces quelques
centaines de milliers que l'allemagne de
réfugiés à envisager centaines de
milliers devenu 800 mille huit cent
mille devenu en quelques heures à peine
2 par la bouche officielle du vision du
vice-chancelier un million et pourquoi
pas plus
qu'est-ce que cela démontre cher jean
dominique ça démontre que l'europe vit
aujourd'hui une anarchie migratoires
c'est ça la réalité je vais juste aussi
parenthèse en passant c'est une anarchie
migratoires à l'échelon européen mais
qui vient aussi de la politique menée en
france où le gouvernement français a
fait preuve en quelques mois d'une
élasticité parfaite
qu'est-ce que c'était avril mais le
gouvernement annonce qu'il est hostile
totalement hostile aux quotas
il y est aujourd'hui totalement
favorable en avril mais le gouvernement
annonce que 9200 réfugiés c'est
totalement inacceptable
aujourd'hui 24 milles c'est totalement
acceptable et bienvenus il faut rajouter
les soixante deux mille demandes de
statut de réfugié et ainsi de suite en
avril mais le gouvernement dira ça ne
pourra pas se mettre en place ce partage
parce que les états européens ils sont
hostiles
aujourd'hui le même gouvernement
explique qu'il imposera avec d'autres
qu'il n'imposera à d'autres pays
européens
en quelques mois à peine totale
contradiction
alors que faut-il faire il ya beaucoup
de choses et toute la journée je
remercie guillaume eric et les autres
d'avoir pris l'initiative de cette
journée chacun apportera des solutions
mois françois noël m'a dit je vais pas
plus de 47 minutes de temps de parole
dont je vais les utiliser jusqu'à la
dernière seconde ça va de soi
mais donc je vais simplement vous donner
quelques exemples sur schengen
il ya d'autres choses beaucoup d'autres
choses schengen qu est ce que c est une
idée formidable je suis d'accord avec
jean dominique formidable imaginez en
1985 appliquée en 1995 l'idée c'était on
peut circuler librement dans un espace
intérieur sans qu'il y ait besoin de
donner son passeport liberté formidable
c'était cinq états au départ nous en
sommes comme l'a dit je crois constance
à 26 aujourd'hui et donc on voit avec
cette crise que ça ne répond plus aux
possibilités aux besoins aux attentes
aux nécessités et donc il faut changer
les choses il faut refonder schengen oui
il faut s'appuyer sur les textes
existants mais ils sont pas forcément
suffisant je crois qu'il ya trois
initiatives à prendre je passe sous le
couvert de claude guéant qui connaît
parfaitement ses sujets aussi je crois
qu'il ya trois initiatives d'abord il
faut définir un périmètre
un nouveau périmètre des états membres
qu'ils s'engagent à respecter et
appliquer des politiques communes et on
voit au travers du fiasco et sap a été
tellement présenté comme ça en dit oui
c'est plus ou moins équilibrés le fiasco
du conseil de la réunion des ministres
européens
il ya deux jours où c'est un
aboutissement a été à rien si ce n'est
du blabla et pourquoi parce que des
états ont expliqué des condés des rentes
avancée des positions totalement
divergentes des autres donc il faut dire
on réduit le périmètre européen à ceux
qui partagent les mêmes convictions
deuxième élément il faut effectivement
prévoir la possibilité de s'extraire de
schengen lorsqu'il ya une crise
migratoire ont dit oui mais regardez
l'allemagne c'est ce qu'elle a fait non
l'allemagne a utilisé un artifice
juridique pour s'extraire de schengen
l'allemagne n'a pas dit qu'ils
suspendaient les schengen avec
l'autriche parce qu'il y avait une crise
migratoire il en allemagne a dit qu'ils
suspendaient schengen parce que il y
avait des menaces à l'ordre public
oui ça existe
jean-dominique dans les traiter soi-même
été appliqué très exactement à 30
reprises
simplement c'est pas le motif s'était
appliqué à 30 mètres entreprise je vous
donnerai deux trois exemples ça a été
appliquée en 1995 lorsque les pays bas
ont décidé de légaliser le cannabis
on a décidé de suspendre schengen parce
qu'on considérait que ça pouvait
entraîner une atteinte à l'ordre public
même chose au moment des attentats sur
le rer b
ça a été utilisé par l'allemagne au
moment de la coupe du monde en 2006 ça a
été utilisé aussi par la france quand il
ya eu des attentats aux états unis mais
c'étaient des mesures d'ordre public
il faut que cela soit prévu prévu
expressément dans le cas d'une réforme
en cas de trouble à l'ordre public a de
pression migratoire et non pas
simplement ne trouve la rue
troisième élément il faut aussi que
lorsqu'un état est défaillant c'est à
dire qu'ils n'assurent pas la protection
des frontières ou qui ne respectent pas
ce qui est prévu précisément par
schengen
il faut que l'on puisse décider là aussi
de suspendre
c'était un peu il peut y avoir des
raisons à cela il peut y avoir un
changement de majorité politique dans
l'état concerné qui dit bah voilà nous
en ce moment un désaccord ainsi dit donc
il faut pas que ça soit figé vaut que
les autres puissent dire écoutez on
constate que vous remplissez pas vos
obligations donc on les suspend ça peut
être le cas d'une situation financière
budgétaire qui fait qu' on y puise n'ont
plus les moyens et donc il faut que l'on
puisse et la troisième réforme que l'on
puisse décider d'extraire un état
provisoirement de ses obligations de
schengen ce qui suppose naturellement
aussi de décider de suspendre un certain
nombre de fonds européens et notamment
le fonds européen de sécurité intérieure
qui contribuent au financement
ensuite il ya une autre initiative j'en
aurai terminé et initiatives axées yade
qui a été un excellent diplomate on en
parlait avec clown un excellent
diplomate à la représentation permanente
à bruxelles et qui connaît parfaitement
ses sujets et il m'avait donné cette
idée à l'époque qu'il fallait sans doute
réfléchir la création d'une agence pour
l'asile
qui dit avoir dénaturé les politiques
d'asile mais il faut qu'elle soit
détournement commune et donc pour
accélérer pour en plus efficace pour que
cela soit plus sérieux plus crédible il
faut sans doute prendre l'initiative de
créer cette agence alors je suis pas par
tempérament favorable aux créations des
agents avons 500 déjà en france claude
connaît tout ça par coeur coups de
gueule ça veut pas dire que claude
guéant et connaissent pas mais enfin
claude goasguen les suit et donc mais là
je pense que ça serait sincèrement utile
enfin dernier mot je vous fais part voie
d'une conviction qui est une conviction
personnelle très forte
hélas les rares cheveux de jean
dominique giuliani vont se dresser
je pense que le système de libre
circulation est totalement à bout de
souffle et que nous ne ferons pas
l'économie
je l'espère à court terme mais je suis
quasiment sûr un moyen terme l'économie
d'un changement radical la libre
circulation au sein de l'espace européen
devra être réservé aux citoyens
européens
chaque état a le droit d'accueillir
qu'il veut sur son territoire en
fonction de sa démographie en fonction
de ses besoins économiques l'allemagne à
un million huit cent mille postes non
pourvus
nous on en a que trois cent mille la
situation n'est pas la même en allemagne
il y as depuis les années 70 plus de
décès que de naissances chaque année ce
qui n'est pas le cas chez nous dont
chaque état peut décider de sa politique
simplement les étrangers qui sont admis
dans l'état ne doivent pas pu une fois
qu'ils ont arrivés dans cet état pouvoir
se promener dans tout le reste de
l'europe et notamment examiner comment
bénéficie au mieux des prestations et je
termine pas là je vous rappelle que les
prestations actuelles c'est de 1 à 9
selon les différents pays ce qui n'est
plus acceptable je vous remercie